Romi would you say that success is not
free and it comes with a price
okay yeah but
see a lot of times people like saying
well you're not successful you're you're
not uh starring in in A-list movie
you're not in The Avengers
success is relative
you can be successful
by just you know being able to get on
the stage or get get in an audition and
do a good audition
but it does come with a price
everything comes to the price no matter
what you do whether you're an actor or a
plumber or whatever
there's always going to be something in
your life that's gonna you know be a
challenge to you
and success
most people don't have most people have
a problem not with success
well no no let me say that again most
people
have a problem with success
as opposed to failure
because most people expect to fail
but a lot of that not most people don't
expect to succeed
most people that's why that's why a lot
of actors can't handle success
they can handle it because first of all
they weren't expecting to succeed
and have success and then once they got
it
it didn't come or it didn't they didn't
react to it or it wasn't like they
thought it was going to be I'm
successful now and um I can I can do
these things okay yeah you're successful
but
you're still lonely
depending on who you are you still have
problems with your wife or your husband
or whoever a girlfriend or whoever
boyfriend you still have these things
you still have other things going on in
your life no matter whether you're
successful or not you still have money
problems because the more money you make
the more people want your money
and the more you're going to spend
success
success is is not an easy thing
and and to me it's more is is not easy
just because
it's hard to deal with it you're not
expecting it for one and then it's hard
to handle
it's hard to handle
and and that's that's that's what
that's what uh that's what
differentiates the
the people that can handle success and
are able to keep moving on and the
people that fall by the wayside I mean
I I don't even want to mention some of
these actors we know that have become
successful and completely went off
Durant well just went right off the
track
because they just had expectations about
it and either it didn't happen the way
they thought it was going to be once
they achieved success or they tripped
out all the way because they're
successful
and then they in about nowhere
under the freeways you got a ton of
people in in refrigerator boxes and and
intense
that were successful people at one point
I had an experience in Chicago where I
was in in a in in Grant Park if you've
ever been in Chicago Grand Park
and I was working on a
working on a scene for uh
for an audition
and a man came and sat on on the little
bench towards the end down there
and I looked at him I'm like oh okay and
I started listening to what he was
talking about
this man was talking
uh
scientific equations and
in calculus and
and
whatever engineering he was talking in
in babbling and talking that kind of
thing and I was like
he was
talking about I knew that the the system
in in the in the specifications and he
was gone
and I was like wow
you never know
what people have gone through are going
through
whether they're successful or not
you never know it's like wow that's
pretty deep
I mean here this man just
a a bomb
and just hear what he's talking about in
in his in his delirium you know it's
like
wow
so at that point I'm like
careful dude
you know careful
don't get out over your skis now don't
don't let your ego take you out see a
lot of times success what happened was
it was success the ego takes over and it
happens to everybody to a point I mean
I'm not going to sit here and say I
haven't tripped out on some things
before in my life no we all have tripped
out on some things that's just being
human but but you got to understand when
you trip out
why are you tripping out and why what
you're tripping out over is really not
that important okay
and you're really not all you think you
are at that point
that's why I said early on
I don't have time to be different than
who I am I'm not I'm gonna be me you
know
that's boring to me it's like well I'm
so you know no get away from me with
that
that's why that's why I like
that's why when I I I I I I I get away
from this stuff
like after I record when I get home I'm
taping the draft he knows I'm into that
football I'm into that
you know the Draft starts tonight that's
you know and I'm from Detroit so my team
is not one in 60 years so the draft is
like the Super Bowl
who we gonna pick
that's not going to do anything for us
now we might be better now okay that's
another story but I get away from this
that's why
I was I went out with a lady and
we clicked and everything except for the
fact that
she couldn't turn it off
you got to turn this stuff off
you got to turn off everything
you can't you can't be in work mode 24
hours a day
you got to turn this off
and she was wondering like wow we can't
seem to we know I said I like you but
you can't turn this off I don't want to
talk
shop 24 hours a day I don't want to be
cuddled up talking about
oh I hope this audition is like oh stop
just get away please
you got to be human you got to get away
from this
that's what destroys people and
everything no matter what you do it's
when you can't let it go and just say
okay that's this here
let me be a regular person over here
that's why I dated a woman years ago in
Chicago in the medical field and
she always she told me one time says now
when you get here please don't let my
medical all these medical people please
don't let my friends start talking and
and you know what you'll do I said what
will I do she said you'll have everybody
just phoning over you and everything I
said because I'm not in the medical
field
and they want to talk to somebody that's
not doing what they do
she's like uh-huh I said
I said why would a bunch of doctors and
people like that
want to get to a party and have a guy
like me come in there that's not even in
it and that have seen me on TV or
something they gonna come to me say I
saw you on this what was it like you
know and I said oh it was like you know
I explained that like that but what it
is is like you got to get away and see
being successful is part of that that's
what keeps people grounded
and that's why a lot of people can't
make it because success destroys them
everybody can fail because in this
business you failing 99 of the time so
you're used to that the success is what
gets you
that's what gets you how you handle that
because at one point you're gonna get
something that's you're gonna be good at
and you are going to succeed at is how
you handle it and if you can't handle it
you're gone